>> COMPUTER: Welcome to Google I/O.
[ music playing ]
>> Never underestimate the web.
>> Google I/O is about a celebration of that
open web platform.
[ music playing ]
>> The web is the development platforms for
our time.
[ music playing ]
>> SCHMIDT: This is the beginning of the real
win of cloud computers, of the real win of
applications, of the real win of the Internet.
[ music playing ]
>> Yes, the web has won. It has become the
dominant programming model of our time.
[ music playing ]
>> The web is going to drive the innovation
and the new services that are going to do
amazing things for people all around the world.
[ music playing ]
>> Hold your applause. If you like that, wait
till you see this. You will forget that you
are looking at the browser.
[ music playing ]
>> Are you having a good time?
>> I've always wanted an Oprah moment, so,
for you and you, and you.
[ music playing ]
>> I think they like it.
>> They like it.